In 2019, Steven Wilson, founder of the
high-performing Ascend charter school
network, wrote that efforts to make
schools more "equitable" and "inclusive"
could wind up morphing into lowered
expectations. Wilson wrote that the civil
rights community had sometimes erred in
allowing rigor to be seen as racist and
argued that intellectual joy is good for
all students of every race and background.
Astonishingly, Wilson's lofty
sentiments were labeled as "white
supremacist rhetoric" by an online
petition, a galling accusation given
Wilson's lifetime of work expanding
educational opportunity. Yet, in response
to the petition, Ascend fired Wilson. The
charter school community responded with silence.
The whole episode raises
questions about whether charter schools
will choose groupthink over bedrock
educational principles. For a sector that
has been defined by bold, innovative
leadership, the answer will prove telling.
Do you think groupthink is becoming a
problem in American education? Let us
know in our poll. Also, let us know what
other topics you'd like our scholars to
cover in 60 seconds, and be sure to LIKE
and subscribe for more research and
videos from AEI.